Speaker 1: With young and deeply unqualified
Congressman Madison Cawthorn losing his
primary challenge in North Carolina. There was
apparently an opening in the Tarheel State for
another 20 something year old Republican to enter
Congress and be in completely over their head.
Insert Beau Hines, 26 years old, who is
running for Congress on the Republican
ticket to represent the 13th District of North
Carolina. He made headlines this week for not
knowing the definition of a banana republic and
confusing it with the retail clothing store.
He did this while trying to make the point, by the
way, that it is Joe Biden who is the one who is
incompetent and incoherence. Hines was on the John
Fredericks radio show and the two were talking
about the FBI raid on Donald Trump and the Biden
administration's plan to hire more IRS agents.
Republicans lately have loved to lump these two
issues together as if they have anything to do
with one another. They don't. More on that on the
show later. And then Beau made the case that even
though there's all these corrupt people in the
highest ranks of our government, it's not fair to
call the United States a banana republic, because
that's an insult to Banana Republic stores all
across the country. Let's take a look at the clip.
Speaker 3: You get the Congress. Is it going to
be real? Are we actually going to be willing to
defund IRS, FBI and things of that nature? I mean,
we have to I mean, we're at a point in our
country now we have a unregulated fourth branch of
government that's targeting middle class Americans
on a daily basis. I mean, it's unbelievable.
A lot of people have, like in the situation that's
going on right now is, you know, they say we're in
a banana republic. I think that's an insult to
banana republics across the country. I mean, at
least the manager of Banana Republic, unlike our
president, knows where he is and why he's there
and what he's doing. I mean, we have a president
right now that doesn't know where he is, doesn't
know who he is or what time it is. And he's
attempting to run our country. At the same time,
this fourth unregulated branch of government,
which is the FBI, the DOJ, targeting Americans
every single day. I mean, it's unbelievable.
Speaker 1: My absolute favorite part of that
clip is the radio hosts reaction to it all. He has
this look of, oh, crap, this guy doesn't know what
a banana republic is. Should I correct damage?
Should I just let it slide? What exactly do I do?
How do I run? Cover for what's going on here? Now
the campaign is in damage control mode. They're
trying to say that this was all just a joke, even
though there was no laugh or smile or indication
at all that what he was saying was in jest, Rob
Burgess, his senior adviser, said in response,
It's clear now that the American people can add
understand a joke to the ever growing list of
things Democrats simply can't comprehend alongside
the economy, public safety, education and foreign
policy just to name a few. So he's trying to brush
it off as just a joke before quickly transitioning
to these other topics, which I actually have
to give Burgess credit for, because these are
actual issues facing the country. It's not just
the typical culture war nonsense that the right
loves to talk about these days. So definitely
this is a funny story, but it actually serves
as a reminder to maybe retire the term Banana
Republic because it is often used as a pejorative
against Latin American countries. That describes a
small country that's politically and economically
unstable and relies too much on exporting
natural resources. The term was actually coined
to describe countries that were being exploited by
American companies like the United Fruit Company,
which is now Chiquita Brands, which was a state
favored monopoly that exploited Latin American
workers for profit for many years. Maybe once
we retire, the term only the retail store will
be left with the name Banana Republic, and then
both sides will be vindicated. He'll be correct
if he ever tries to make this a statement again.
We'll follow up on this race because Hines is up
against Democrat Wiley Nicol and the contest is
seen as a toss up, maybe a slight edge to Hinds,
but it's definitely winnable. So we'll have
to see if will be able to win this race.